One of the challenges with keeping a
system secure is making sure that no one
gains access to our authentication
credentials. This very often includes a
username and most importantly a
password. This password is usually
something secret and we want to be able
to store this information in a way so
that we can verify that the user really
is typing in the correct password when
they log in. Sometimes you'll run across
an application that stores passwords in
the clear. This means this application
is storing all of these passwords in a
human-readable form, usually in one
single file that's somewhere located in
this application. This means if an
attacker does come across this file,
they'll have access to every username
and every password for this application.
If you ever find an application that is
storing information in this way, it's
always a best practice to either not use
the application or find some other
method for storing those password files.
This is why it's always a good best
practice to never store passwords as
their plain text format and to always
use a format that would be very
difficult for an attacker to be able to
discover what that password happened to
be.
And if you are using an application that
is storing all of these passwords in a
non-hashed in the clear method, you
should consider using a different
application or finding a way to modify
the current application to store this
information securely.
This is where hashing steps in. Hashing
is a way to represent data as a
fixed-length string of text. You'll
often hear this referred to as a message
digest or very often as a fingerprint.
For example, us humans could capture our
fingerprint and someone else could be
able to compare fingerprints to see if
one of those happened to match me. What
you can't do is take that fingerprint
and somehow reconstruct the individual
it was associated with. This works the
same way with cryptography. We can take
a hash of a password, and if we want to
take another hash later to compare those
hashes, we would be able to determine if
someone was using the same password.
One interesting characteristic of
hashing is that different types of
inputs will create very different types
of hashes. This allows us to have
passwords stored in this hash form, but
have no way to tell how long that
password is, how complex the password
might be, or what the differences are
between one password and another.
Hashing is also not the same thing as
encryption. You can't undo the hash and
somehow recreate the password, the
stored file, or the video document. This
makes hashing a very useful way to store
passwords because there's no way to look
at the hash and have any idea what your
password happened to be.
Let's look at an example of some
passwords and what the resulting hash
is. The hashing algorithm we're using in
this example is SHA-256. So, you could
try taking these same passwords, putting
them through a SHA-256 hash generator,
and you would come up with exactly the
same hashes that I have here. For
example, I took the password 123456,
and you can see the resulting hash for
that password. I also took the password
of 1234567,
and you can see that the resulting hash
is very different than the one that was
just one character off. This is also an
important characteristic of hashing that
every password, even if it's changed
just a little bit, results in a very
different hash. Here's also the hashes
for qwerty. You can see it listed out,
and the password for the word password,
and you can see that hash. Notice also
that each one of these hashes is exactly
the same length, even though the
passwords we used had a different number
of characters.
You can view these hashes in your
operating system if you know where to
look. I grabbed one of my Linux boxes
and looked at the shadow file, which
contains all of the usernames, the user
ID numbers, and the hash associated with
each user's password. This is obviously
a protected file in the Linux operating
system and not everybody has access to
this information because if you know the
hash, there are things you can do to try
to determine what the password might be.
I mentioned earlier that we can't
reverse engineer a hash and somehow come
up with the original data. This is a
one-way trip when we're hashing. So, one
of the ways that we could take a hash
and determine what the password might be
would be to try every possible
combination of letters, numbers, and
characters and compare those
combinations to the hash that we have
currently stored. We refer to this as a
brute force attack. As you can imagine,
going through every possible combination
of letters, numbers, and special
characters might take quite a bit of
time. And the longer the password, the
longer it takes to cycle through a brute
force attack for that particular hash.
Let's try a brute force attack against a
hash to see what that might entail. I
have a single hash on the screen and
currently we don't know what password is
associated with that hash. So, we're
going to start performing a brute force
attack. We know on this system that it
can take a minimum of five characters as
a password, so we will start with the
password AAAAA.
That's five characters of A and you can
see the hash associated with five A's.
If we compare this with the hash that
we've stored, we can see that these are
very different hashes, so we know that
the password associated with our hash is
not AAAAA.
Let's try the next one in this list,
which would be and we'll get the hash.
We can see those don't match,
so we'll go to the next, which is AAAAC,
and compare those hashes, and those
hashes don't work either. So, we will
continue going through this cycle of
changing one character at a time to try
to determine if we can find a matching
hash. Eventually, you will find a hash
that does match. We finally found one
when we reached the p a s s w o r d
combination. And if we see the hash for
the word password, we can see that it
matches the original hash. Therefore,
we've finally been able to perform a
brute force attack and determine that
our stored hash is for the word
password. Depending on the system that
you're using, what you're searching for,
and the process that you're using to
perform this brute force, this could
take a number of minutes, it could take
hours, or it could take days.
If you were doing this interactively
with an online brute force, then you
would manually type in a username and
manually try a password. You would
perform this multiple times. You would
log in with professormesser.com and try
the password a a a a a. That didn't
work, so let's try the next one. The
professormesser login with a password of
a a a a b. That one did not work either,
and you continue cycling through until
you find the right password. The problem
with doing this online, of course, is
that most accounts are going to lock out
after a small number of failed password
attempts, which means even if you do
come across the correct password, the
system is already locked out that
account, and it will not tell you that
you've actually found the right
password.
This is why most attackers prefer an
offline brute force attack. Once
attackers gain access to that hash
password file, they can then download
that file and begin performing an
offline brute force attack. This is much
faster than performing an online brute
force. This allows them to calculate the
password hash, compare it to what is
stored, see if there's a match, and if
there isn't, they can increment that
brute force value and make another
comparison. This is obviously going to
cycle through thousands and thousands of
potential password attempts as we go
through the process of trying to brute
force just one single hash in that file.
So, we can take that shadow file that I
gathered from my Linux machine. We can
now see all of the hashes associated
with these and now the attacker can sit
offline and cycle through all of these
in an attempt to determine what these
passwords might be. Attackers can also
speed up this process by using
cloud-based resources where they can
have multiple devices across many
different locations all working together
to try to reverse engineer all of these
hashes.
Instead of going through every possible
combination of letters, numbers, and
special characters, why don't we focus
on words that humans tend to use? This
will certainly speed up the brute force
process because we're not checking every
possible combination and we might
actually run across some passwords
because humans like to use words that we
recognize. We refer to this type of
directed attack as a dictionary attack.
This is because we're using words that
you might find in any type of
dictionary. You might also find custom
word lists as well. If you're trying to
brute force passwords that are
associated with a law firm or with a
hospital, you might want to use a
dictionary attack that specializes in
those types of terms. Some of these
dictionary attacks can even enhance the
search process by adding in or changing
different letters as part of that
dictionary attack. So, instead of using
the word password of all characters, it
might automatically change the A to an
ampersand, the O to a zero, and so on.
This obviously still takes time to go
through the brute force process, but
we're obviously using a much smaller
group of words to be able to brute
force. This speeds up the overall
process and might give you a large
percentage of passwords.
If you have users that like to use
passwords with letters and numbers or
jumbled up phrases, then a dictionary
attack probably is not going to identify
those specific passwords. But, if you
have people using a password like ninja,
that's a very easy one to find in a
dictionary attack. The same thing
applies to passwords such as dragon,
football, let me in, or the password of
password. Although passwords do provide
a very useful factor during the
authentication process, you can see now
why we might want to add additional
factors along with our username and
password.